face à la pénurie de bras les salons de
coiffure tentent de trouver la parade
10000 postes sont à pourvoir en France
alors la prime va aujourd'hui au plus
offrant Ellen chapelet s'est rendu dans
un salon de Blois là-bas les nouveaux
salariés peuvent choisir de travailler
le weekend ou pas
dans ce salon de coiffure Blaise on
recherche de nouveaux collaborateurs
pour travailler à plein temps
qui s'avère plus compliqué que prévu car
depuis le covid la profession a perdu
3500 salariés les motifs de se
désintéresse ont connu auraient
contraignants pénibilité physique et
salaire peu attractif pourtant ici le
gérant a décidé de faire bouger les
lignes ces nouveaux collaborateurs ne
travailleront plus le week-end mais du
lundi au vendredi
ces personnes là pourraient donc
bénéficier de leur samedi et donc
voilà le but c'est effectivement de
proposer quelque chose de différent pour
séduire des candidats qui aujourd'hui
seraient déjà en place dans des salons
et qui travailleraient d'une façon
différente une proposition pour se
démarquer de la concurrence et donner
envie à des coiffeurs déjà en poste et
qui travaillerait le samedi de rejoindre
son équipe mais aussi une adaptation à
l'air du temps où l'on cherche à mieux
concilier vie professionnelle et vie
familiale
aujourd'hui les gens ont envie de
pouvoir partir en week-end avec des amis
de pouvoir organiser donc une vie
parallèle et voilà il faut il faut
prendre tout ça en compte on peut pas
considérer que les gens qui pensent
autrement ont tort et par conséquent il
faut essayer de s'adapter
ferme le salon pourrait donc ouvrir 6
jours sur 7 du lundi au samedi car
d'ancien collaborateurs souhaite
continuer à travailler les samedis du
côté de la clientèle on y voit que des
avantages je pense que c'est une bonne
initiative mais que ça reste quand même
important je pense de rester ouvert le
samedi ou tout du moins le samedi matin
dans le sens où il faut peut-être
s'adapter aussi à tout le monde avoir un
employeur comme ça avec autant
d'empathie pour ses collaborateurs
chapeau que c'est super c'est super en
disant le secteur de la coiffure a perdu
près de 15000 actifs pour continuer à
faire tourner leurs entreprises les
patrons n'ont plus d'autres choix que de
faire évoluer les conditions de travail